RTI is about proud
GTC EU which is one of our TP
conferences we did that earlier this
month so there's an open source project
called Rapids and it's how we're helping
to accelerate data science there's a lot
of content here I've also got a lot of
demo the projectors a little wonky so
I'm doing the best they can here if
there's things that are hard to see let
me know but let's try to do all the
questions towards the end so as anyone
that was that is doing data science
there's a lot of challenges namely I
mean there's just a few to name off here
but like interoperability feature and
engineering and data ingest is kind of
expensive experimentations speed is key
and I'll highlight that in a second then
also the increase of the amount of data
that is available you know we kind of
went through this period back in 2012
and 2013 and then all the way to like
even with some companies still today of
let's just capture everything throw it
into a data Lake and we'll sample it but
as everything grows that trend of
sampling just kept going right like
we're just going to take this little
piece of sample or you know even though
we have years of data we can only
process it like a week at a time or
something like that and really with
Rapids what we're trying to do is to
break that and actually be able to say
let's look at the entire data set and do
it very quickly so what happens when you
usually kind of like fire off a job
right you're like oh time to go get a
coffee it's gonna run maybe overnight
maybe for a week there was some rain one
really retailer I was working with it's
like yeah we run this job and it's seven
seven days like for a Turin run for us
to do one week of processing I've heard
those of you that are Futurama like
Attucks that's the APIs ode to the 300
big ones so one of my colleagues that I
work with Alan and Mark it's at exactly
Allen he made this awesome chart and I
was really blurry for you guys
definitely look at the video that's
gonna be posted online it's going to be
like full high-res and I apologize about
this but on the CPU powered side
basically let me see if I can actually
maybe make this a little bit bigger
let's do it old-school a little too much
step back
sorry apologize alright so like on the
GPU our sorry CPU power work flow you
know you kind of start at 9:00 in the
morning you're configuring your ETL
workflow you start the workflow you get
a coffee it's still running you get
another coffee green here is while your
data is running or you know your ETL
process and stuff that's running or
while you're training red is the time
that you're actually working then
another word in past noon and crap you
know you forgot to add feature say
restart the ETL workflow eventually you
have to fit realize you're switching a
decaf and then you find a bunch of
unexpected null values stored as a
string started again and then it goes
into a pass and the one thing that's cut
off down here is the state late so
really what we're trying to do is kind
of change this paradigm so well with the
GPU powered workflow it's more of you
know you get into nine you configure it
you start it and then it's done then you
can play with it again and like so this
is where you can start being able to do
these like narrow down at that time it
takes to get that experimentation and
get those results back and then you know
even when you run into the same problems
of saying you forgot to add the feature
you ran into you know all these dreams
like the panel team there is not as high
as it was on the CPU side so we can keep
going through and then quickly move from
the ETL process because a lot of times
you know 80% of the work sometimes in
doing what you need to is the ETL
process everything else the training and
like those are kind of like known it's
getting everything that your data
specifically into those algorithms and
so they will work takes most of the
amount of time and the one thing that
gets cut off here which is actually you
know important for everybody in this
room is go home on time
and so if we think about what like the
kind of defect of data science platform
is on the CPU side that I was talking
about for you got python panda psych SK
learn and then numpy and one of the
things that we can do is you know to get
not to worry about with the
interoperability issues that we talked
about previously is to use tasks tasks
as Python you know allows you to go
through and scale these workloads very
quickly and almost effortlessly because
you don't really have to say oh now I
have to change everything for this new
framework or this new technology but if
we think about where we've kind of come
from I mentioned Hadoop before there's
like kind of what we started at the top
of being a Hadoop were way of doing
queries ETO and machine learning trained
on these very large clusters thousands
of nodes if if not tens of thousands and
it takes a very long time so if you
think about the width of the slide or
the y-axis or sorry x-axis is being time
then like it takes pretty like the full
slide length now when we think about
like spark we started getting like
magnitudes of improvements 25 200 X
we've got a couple benefits less code
language flexibility you know instead of
just everything being in Java you can
all do stuff of Python with high spark
and then also it's primarily in memory
so these complicated and expensive reads
and writes to disk no longer happened
but one of the things that we start
running into on the CPU side is there's
only so much scaling as you can do that
retailer I was talking about a train on
a 4,000 node smart cluster and it still
takes them a week to do that because
even though the data set is so large you
can only paralyze it so much and then
you start running into problems with
networking discs like all these other
limitations that when you scale out to
that part you start seeing in the graph
where what that says is 5 CPUs 10 15 20
25 and then there's one box before GPUs
down there so you can kind of see the
the difference even though I'm scaling
up the number of C
use the performance of just a box with
four GPUs in it is much better
so speaking of GPUs or the winner right
we're just gonna put some GPUs in there
everything's gonna be different just
like krusty added some speed holes to
his car the problem here though we
didn't get the same speed-up that we
thought we were going to get we got five
to ten X then and one of the reasons why
we were having that is because of if you
think about query the TTL process and
the machine learning process each one of
those was a different GPU package or a
different different application and that
had a different format for storing
memory on the GPU than the next one so
anytime you went from the next stage you
had to copy and convert out through the
CPU which is expensive and takes a very
long time and that's where you start
seeing these CPU write in those dark
boxes they're where we start getting
that penalty hit and a challenging thing
that we saw about a year ago with this
and led us to the initial project called
GP open analytics initiative was we
needed a common data frame to be able to
hand data back and forth between all
these GPU processes and then depending
on the workflow a lot of like if some of
these things were so quickly GPU but it
was so expensive to do that copy and
convert that 80% of your entire time
would be spent doing that so obviously
we were like we need to be able to do do
better so good news everyone right if
anyone like is looking for a class
Rapids it doesn't actually exist that's
just me being funny but that's where
Rapids comes in so rabbit accelerated
platform integrating data science so one
of the things that we wanted to be able
to do was not actually go through and
just say okay great we've got GPUs throw
out all your old code come over to my
platform and build it all brand-new
again
trust me I've also done cybersecurity
research in the past and trying to talk
to anybody that has spent lots of
millions of dollars on hardware software
you tell them that and there's not
same thing with developers so this was
our approach of saying okay how can we
open source something back to the
community but also make it that it's
workable for you guys without having to
have like this large overhead of being
able of having to like redesign
everything that you've already done so
where does the kind of Rapids sit you
know we talked about the CPU kind of dev
stack and this is the GPU one so at the
top we've got Python off to the side the
deep learning frameworks the things that
are in green are what Rapids is
currently working for it's got a hard to
see but the small box on the right to
DNN rapids is this one big piece here
where it comprises comprised of qdf
which is the data frame piece that I
mentioned before
ku ml the machine learning piece to
graph so graph operations all that sits
on top of CUDA which allows that
interface to the GPUs to do a lot of
these functions and then we're flanked
by tasks and arrow
so Apache arrow is one of the projects
that is here on the left
they also saw this from the CPU side
like if you're thinking about big data
space I'm in SPARC I need to go to hive
I'm in HBase wherever I need to go
there's a copy convert there to also
goes through the CPU also takes a long
time because everyone stores things just
a little bit differently an arrow is
this initiative to say okay how can we
actually all speak the same language how
can we have the same metadata around
things and then be able to do these
types of operations in memory so when we
could so we can pass these pointers
around and that's where the GPU data
frame comes in and our goal through the
process and a lot of these some of these
features have already actually been
incorporated into the Apache Aero since
0.7 I want to say where we're actually
going through and the data frame
features that are uniquely specific for
GPUs are actually being integrated back
into Apache
Aero but they are compatible so then it
starts opening up even this larger
ecosystem where if you did have
excuse me like a big data he goes like
big data set up and you've got hive and
sparking I think spark it's 2.3
something where they started doing full
arrow support where you can now export
these arrow and then bring it in with
rapid digest it and then start doing
machine learning and training and then
digest out or send back out an arrow
data frame so this now starts being able
to be like the glue that was missing
between all of these all these different
applications so now where does that get
us you know we've gone through the
lineage now we're down towards the
bottom where now we're seeing that
magnitude and more speed of improvement
so now we're getting to the point where
like you know we have the same code
there's minor changes and that kind of
stuff to it we're starting to language
flexible this is mostly all been written
for Python first
excuse me however the underpinnings for
the data frame and that kind of stuff
are actually C modules so there is no
reason why if somebody's in here is like
I'm a you know huge advocate of are
always fork off of that and start having
the same or like our bindings that we've
done with I thought to expose the same
primitives and functions and now the
last part there is we're primarily on
GPU so instead of this being a situation
where you know I oh I'm going to be for
this part and then I have to like hop
off and hop back on now all my
operations are there because once the
data is query I can just hand the
pointer off to my ETL ETL does what it
needs to do ants that pointer off to the
machine learning and I'm able to do the
machine learning all without leaving the
GPU so how does that kind of compare and
a side-by-side so on the left hand side
we've got kind of what SPARC ecosystem
is and then on the right side is the
rapid GPU ecosystem where it's similar
layers that can talked about before over
here we've got you know rapid primitives
some of the arrays and stuff that I will
talk about in a little bit and the
connectors sitting on top of that is
kudiye ql
kuu graph that allows us to be able to
do those different operations and you
see the similar things on the spark side
so like spark you know they have a lib
they've got graphics and then also stuff
to be able to manipulate data frames
themselves and one of the points here is
like you know more cores higher
bandwidth because you can actually see
like 20 cores for the CPU on or twenty
eight gigabytes a second per CPU versus
you know we're nine hundred gigabytes a
second per GPU and five thousand and 120
CUDA cores so the whole thing here is
about trying to paralyze and process the
data faster and as fast as possible so
let's take a deep dive because I know
somebody's asking would you like to
network so Rapids open source software
how does it also kind of look the GPU
memory interacting with patchy arrow is
kind of like the base layer we've got
these different pieces that I've talked
about crude EF is more around the
analytics so even though we are
integrating with Apache arrow there are
going to be certain things that Apache
arrow doesn't support right like Maji
arrow is great for defining metadata and
saying like this is what my data looks
like there are going to be some
operations that we're going to want to
do on the GPU and wholly-owned which is
why we're still gonna have like cou DF
as a piece even though like the
functions that kind of stuff might
eventually migrate into Apache arrow
which is the plan there's no still going
to be like a subset of joins and group
bys and filters and like also the kind
of stuff that us handling logic and
being able to do it for the GPUs will be
much faster more efficient and then ku
ml is a some standard machine learning
I've got a couple examples I can show
you if like the three that are available
today machine learning algorithms that
we were actually able to integrate with
ku DF so then if you're eight if you
able to get the information into a GPU
data frame and you're using ku DF then
you're able to use qu ml to actually be
able to process that so that completes
that chain that we were looking at
before like query ETL and
the machine running train ku graph is
not available yet it's in in the process
of being open source but is this similar
reference image singing okay we've got
graph we want to be able to do this on
GPUs we want to do do it faster but also
baking into the GPU data frame how do
you represent graph data and a-come csr
method or compressed sparse method
interaction are we're working with pi
torch and chain or the deep learning
side and then on one of the
visualizations that if you want to check
it out there was a visualization that
was done at GT CEU for the keynote that
was done by also Allen who did the kind
of the data scientist sketch using
Kepler and all of that on the back end
was talking to arrow and using the GPU
data frame with all the data in the GPU
so you can actually visualize much more
data than you would have otherwise just
on a CPU and what we're trying to do is
like kind of this loop of data
preparation model training visualization
and then come back right
so visualizations only get better by
actually going through and like you
start off with a basic visualization
come back through and this iterative
cycle is what actually gets you to the
results are kind of like the aha moments
and by narrowing down the time the
experimentation time that you need to be
able to go through the prep and the
training process you can actually make
that loop what's faster it succinct so
talked about the data processing and
engine so specifically about ku DF
there's a lot of key features and stuff
on there I'm not going to like read off
of all of them but there's a lot of
stuff that we're doing where we can
actually do things faster than spark
with a single V 100 GPU which are
available on cloud providers and then
just being able to like I said some of
the things that I think we're really
interesting is what we're trying to do
I'll touch more on is like input output
formats too so a lot of us deal with CSV
data there's actually a GPU a GPU based
CSV reader which is
just because that tends to be a lot of
the data formats and we're also working
on part parquet and orc integration as
well so we haven't kind of gotten to
like the rest of that list as far as
tender formats but it is coming and 2df
like I mentioned in the previous slide
is directly integrated with ku arrow and
ku graph and then also KU ml so there's
not necessarily like where you have to
go through and you know I install it
multiple times as long as kuma melody F
is already there you can then use a comb
element problem so how did this kind of
integrate with some of the other things
one of the things that were also looked
at was is this number of rate interface
so there's actually a CUDA number array
interface that we've that were
supporting and what this allows us to do
is like that way there's one array
interface and there's not you know I
think at the time we were looking at it
there's our 14 for the Python community
and I've got the pulls later in one of
the other slides but I think like I
torch and a couple other places have
already started like integrating that
it's kind of a de-facto based off of
what numbers been doing and that's full
integration with qtf Kamel and coop
graph so that way there's this also goes
to that whole penalty thing of I have
something in this number array interface
and I don't want to then have to like
pay for the penalty to convert back and
forth and then lastly as I mentioned
before tasks being able to scale this
out so what we've done with one of the
demos that I've got later is we're
actually using gas to actually scale out
across multiple so it's all in the same
node but there are eight GPUs on that
note and we can use gas to basically
individually address each CPU and then
we run these different workloads to be
able to kind of scale out so what is
dancing why is rapids using for scale so
for those of you that have it used to
ask it's great Matt Rocklin and the
others that I've been to read it to it
for the ask I think they've made an
amazing product for us it was really
made sense to kind of go back to
the whole interrupts part we didn't want
to have to build our own scheduler to
say oh you want to operate on CUDA and
GPUs use our CUDA scheduler or whatever
it is by integrating with tasks then it
makes it super easy that basically we
just import ggf or crude EDF into with
the notebook that we're using import the
stuff that we need for task and then
we're able to run without anything else
there and so the next thing I kind of
hinted to is that you can run multiple
task workers per node to allow for the
easier traveler model and like it scales
to however many GPUs you have on that
particular one because a lot of times
when you're thinking about it it's like
you know you might be single node a
single GPU single node and then might
get all squared scared about this whole
like I need to transition to multi node
multi-gpu tasks allows you to do that
very easily without having to really
refactor your code base as well so as
long as it were Unzen - one GPU
generally it will like it'll then easily
scale to multiple GPU single node and so
basically like there's the qu TF
primitive so there is a little bit of
there's - G d/f that we're this reco
that's on github right now that one is
our implementation that we're using of
tasks as just our Fork at the moment
eventually this will be baked in we're
working with Matt Rockland and others at
anaconda to you know make this as
community friendly as possible and one
of the nice awesome parts about this is
the demo that I want to show you later
is basketball also especially with this
version of the task gdf it will handle
what's called our DMA so like one of
that allows you to do is over InfiniBand
or over rocky like within the same node
you can actually bypass the CPU entirely
usually when you're trying to use a
network interface or whatever to
exchange between nodes you still have to
go through CPU with our DMA what you're
allowed to do is
have direct connection between the GPUs
and then that's over InfiniBand or 100
Gigabit Ethernet and that's really where
a lot of the as we start scaling up it's
going out that's where a lot of the
performance gains are shown and then
same thing with KU ml so obviously you
know having something for our DMA and
being able to move data like when you're
doing training is going to be great but
but it handles a lot of this stuff under
the hood that you don't want to really
pay attention to there's an initializing
nickel and like all these other things
turn to give like the environment
created the - gdf environment like that
handles that for you so you don't have
to worry about all the nitty-gritty
there and an example that up here is
just like how the desk actually boosts
so being able to run extra boost and
tasks which I'll show you guys later is
you know cutting new uses this and it
does have to do all of that set up
manually of taking everything so yeah
that's you talk about qtf talked about
KU ml you know kind of where does it
stand like as far as like AI libraries
for like machining learning there's two
ml there's three that are out there
right now there's kind of a like a list
that we're targeting that gain decision
trees random forests linear regressions
logistic regressions k-means k nearest
neighbor DB scan common filtering
principal components single value
decomposition and asian influencing i
know like at least three of these are
definitely done and i think there's
maybe one or two that are also on that
list and I can show you the link to that
repository the next part is for like
profit analysis is PageRank
breadth-first search Jaccard similarity
single source shortest path triangle
counting and lead-in modularity so those
are like the ones that are going to be
in KU graph I know PageRank is
implemented now
not sure on the other the status on the
other ones at the moment but how is this
like really impacting or how does like
crew graph actually impact is I don't
know if anybody's familiar with envy
graph that's kind of something that's
been released by in a CUDA toolkit to
say here this is some primitives like
being able to k-means PageRank a couple
other algorithms while using cuda
there's also gun rock gonna rock is
great because it has a very wide breadth
of like algorithms however it is
constrained to a single node and then
hornet is a different paradigm from
University of Georgia Tech where it's
actually the opposite way it's it's
really good for dynamic graphs so
gunrock is really good for single node
static graphs porn it is really good for
like large-scale dynamic graphs where
you can do millions it up millions in
updates a second so we're trying to
combine all of their work that's been
done with all of these these other
libraries and pull them into KU graph
not necessarily that we want to
replicate them but it's mainly for the
data the data side so can we be able to
have a GPU data frame that then we can
share be able to get it into the rest of
the pipeline use it with qml use it with
all the other ones and qdf without
having to like necessarily go in to the
other three and same thing with
transforms adding the transform function
of at different utilities so so rapid so
how ludicrous right so got some
benchmarks ku DF + XG boost so this is
just in GPU processing it starts with
five nodes of SPARC 10 15 20 25 and then
for be 132 game GPUs so it's all in
seconds
and the number that's actually called
out so like it's it's in seconds but the
number that's called out at the top is
just the X agrees portion so forget the
data prep the MLL transfer and the other
parts that are down there if we just
look at the processing speed
you know we've got 1400 seconds which is
like blanking on that one
but like less than a minute 55 seconds
versus 1400 like 23 minutes between the
two and then the other one has been ten
minutes between a minute so obviously
this allows us to do this full end and
pipeline we're prepping the data doing
whatever we need to on a 35 King data
set and allows us to you can see the you
know kind of like you mentioned before
the CPU kind of like tails off as you
start trying to scale this out further
and then on a single node you can do it
very quickly but where does that stand
for you know out of core stuff what I
mean by this is sometimes when you do
like four actually boost processing like
there's just so much data we can't fit
all of it into a GPU memory all at one
time right so what happens is and this
is the demo I'm going to show you guys
in a little bit is it'll actually go
through and it process and does all the
ETL and then pushes it to system Ram and
then pulls it back in to then do the SG
boos back into back into the GPU memory
to then get it so the GPU results are
stored in the system RAM and then read
back in the GP Ram and this is done with
tasks and task automatically handles
this which is nice so instead of us
having to like kind of build this memory
manager desk
is that taken care of and we can still
see like at the top 20 it's 20 50 100
CPU nodes and then for dgx - it's like
just really tiny and this is all again
in second so we can see like again that
turnaround time of for experimentation
and then like as I mentioned scaling out
the other part is like dgx 2 to 5 dgx
ones so these are just boxes dgx 2 has
16 GPUs in it dgx want has 8 GPUs in it
and we can still see that you know we
can actually get even even a little bit
more speed up I think it's like over 10
minutes and then you know it's just a
little few more than a few minutes by
doing a sh t boost but same format right
we can't fit it all inside the GPUs
stored in system memory and then bring
it back in and a kind of like a staged
approach so just general XG abuse we
have this accelerated and we're pushing
the changes to the extra cheap used
libraries in PRS so the blue line that's
at the bottom and then the other like
kind of lines that are over here these
are different types of GPUs but we can
see that you know this continuing trend
10 to 25 X GPU vs. CPU performance
strong scaling vs. CPU scaling plateau
and then approved accuracy over the CPU
multi node where you know there are some
data sets and that kind of stuff with
CPU or we weren't able to run but on GPU
were able to not only get it done faster
but also have better accuracy there's
just a blow-up of the previous one so
what is the speed up for qml comparison
to scikit-learn one of the things here
so there's three models again it's hard
to see T SVD is the first one here so
yeah so as the number of samples that
increase we can see the speed-up that
happens like for the number of features
that were doing with Kumail versus the
same benchmarks being run on a scale urn
we can see the same thing for G C a and
D be scanned and then also cou graph so
PageRank being run on the G d/f graph so
now we're not doing the copying converts
we're able to actually look at the use
the data keep it in GPU Ram and we're
getting these massive speed ups compared
to the network tax in benchmark that was
done I'm not sure when I've done I can
ask my team for that if anybody's
interested so how can I get started
right so mention the Kuti F so this is
really where the kind of home base would
be stuff as you're in unary binary
operations joins merges provides filters
UDF's and then accelerated fire file
readers like the GPU CSV reader that I
mentioned earlier that's all living in
could EF just a quick like heads up
today right now it's kind of since we
did the announcement at GT CEU last week
or two weeks ago there before I was in
two projects called libgdx DF that were
in GPU of an analytics initiative those
got merged over or moved over to Robyn's
AI project since it's the continuing
project to go forth if you did want to
check out today and start working with
PDF it's Kuti F dash alpha there is a
dotted line between the two because
they're still separate libgdx
C underpinnings where you're you know
wanting to build extensions and that
kind of stuff and PI G d/f is all the
Python
facing so coming soon I'm not sure why
that didn't render but anyway that was
supposed to be a pray for github because
github is not doing too well today but
sometime this week our plan is to freeze
live GTA 5 GTA 5 for the merge so both
of these libraries come together in two
coup DF so it's one repository one build
process everything that we've been doing
is on condo environments so you can do
kinda like environment install and and
also just make it a lot easier to try to
build and kong the packages are coming
hopefully by the end of this week of the
new PDF that's kind of unified so what
is this kind of like look like let me
think
so like you know we said pandas like api
the import the pi GD f and this would
actually be coo TF soon so now we have
you can easily convert from a panda's
data frame back to our to a GPU data
frame so sorry so it's like a one line
operation for you just pi GD f data
frame from pandas so if you've already
have like a process where you're
bringing in data in through pandas you
don't necessarily need to change that
you could like start here at this point
and get started immediately
so so now that you can use all the data
what do you do with it right so with the
live demo hopefully it works basically
I'm gonna run through it real quick and
I'm just going to like kick it off just
a jupiter notebook that i'm running
you go back up to the top so like my
imports and that kind of stuff aren't
necessarily anything gnarly i'm
importing a gdf i'm importing you know
data frames so i can call that and use
that i've got some stuff that i'm
importing - gdf that it gives us that
extensions and I'm just using this kind
of like start task helper script to kind
of dispatch the workers and I can see
that there's the scheduler and then the
different workers and this is running on
a DG x one that has eight GPUs so if I
go to the Status page I think I just
have to restart it so you see that is
live working on it right now all these
green bars are the actual whole ETL
process that's being done this is on
like seven years of data if I'm not
mistaken loan performance and Loan
performance data so we can see like
we're getting up to two hundred and
seven gigabytes that is being offloaded
after we've done the initial ETL process
but even if I inspect some of these like
the you know the individual processes
for that work were like seven seconds
eight seconds and it's just crazy fast
to think about in that time if I go look
at that you know I'm actually going
through here and I'm GPU loading that
acquisition did a GPU loading
performance data
you know normalizing columns and names
and that kind of stuff and saying you
know even though there's low enough
names that are all over the place I want
to change those and normalize it and
then also getting all the performance
data and here I'm actually in create
creating some new features where I want
to actually see did the loans go
delinquent because with that information
then I can actually start training my
model to then predict like is this loan
that's at risk
or not
so let's check back in so now that we've
gotten to this part and there's kind of
like a little stop so right now I've
just done all of the query as far as I
loaded all the data in GPU from CSV
seven years like 200 some gigabytes
hundred some gigabyte 150 200 gigabytes
of data CSV data loaded all that process
it did all the ETL where did all the
name transformations future you know
engineering everything I want to do and
now at the point that I'm at now it's
all doing the Train it's doing the
machine learning model xgv boost and
that will take like about two minutes so
I'll let that run while we go back and
finish this so there's a docker
container out there right now you can do
dr. pool Rapids any ice and I travel to
the latest it has two years of the loan
data in it the acquisition and
performance data as the notebooks in
there one of the ones I just run I ran
and in the pre-built library so like you
don't have to necessarily worry about oh
let me compile could lib gdf IGF and
everything else right now it's limited
to three to nine point two plus so if
your host has nine point two or ten
you're fine but inside the container
it's nine point two updates by the end
of the week is more cou to support like
more different versions and more data
sets so the plan is one two four eight
sixteen and seventeen years so if you
really want it to like push it out or
scale it out you could it's already in
use by some other people's this is one
guy John Marais he's using it do some
cool stuff with some of the
transportation of transformations and
things that he's doing all using
notebook then being able to visualize it
so what else are we working on real
quick to wrap it up so the GPU data
frame so performance and functionality
on the single GPU single node multi-gpu
multi node multi-gpu string support is
coming so ku string there support
there's a lot of string stuff that like
even just the renaming and stuff that I
did there and trying it like without
having the string support it's it's
really sluggish and to try to do in
Canada's so we've actually are writing a
gpu-accelerated string I'm gonna be
relation a library that allows you to do
a lot of the same things and I'll talk
about that okay
alluded to it earlier as far as the
accelerated data loading CSV for GPU CSV
is in park Hayes on its way work is to
start so what is qu string and like how
does it impact me one of the things
there is like you know what about to
lower to find a slice and stuff like
that you know you can see these speed
ups here and it's just like incredible
to be able to do that versus like
sitting there's toiling you know why not
row by row trying to to do this and then
also here's the CSV reader where where
basically it's over ten percent speed
improvement or sorry over 10x speed
improvement over pandas the parkade
reader it is a work in progress so
that's hopefully we'll get merged soon
if not it'll get merged and and then I
mentioned this before so python cuda
array interface so this is where we're
trying to standardize around what number
has been able what numbers been doing as
far as the puter already interface met
with them talked with Anaconda teams and
this is the best way for us to like
support you guys in the community
without coming in and being like here
here's another interface so guess we got
a really get started and you know as we
went there like talked
now I definitely want to go home one
time so you know that's one of the
things that I've excited about being
able to do this workflow and here are
some links to what we can as far as
Apache arrow rapids and GPU open
analytics initiative last one is just if
anyone's interested we are hiring I'll
go back to the other one real quick
so if data scientist data engineers
interns whatever with happy yet happy to
help or have you on our team I'd like to
say this is like one of the first huge
open-source projects that NVIDIA has
done so that's why we also want
involvement from the community and we
also just want feedback just because
typically that's not what we're known
for but that was one of the things that
was very important to myself and the
team that I'm on it was to make sure
that this is open source so we can
actually get it adopted by everyone and
with that
[Applause]